students faculty and alumni at the
university of north carolina at chapel
hill are speaking out in defense of new
york times magazine journalist
nicole hannah jones unc journalist
school announced that
hannah jones who won the pulitzer prize
for her work on the 16-19
project for the new york times magazine
will join the faculty in july
but the university's board of trustees
has not approved her application for
tenure
previous professors in the same role
were offered tenure when they accepted
the position
ed o'keefe has more on the controversy
and the 1619 project
i'm saying that history is history and
we have to tell the truth
journalist nicole hannah jones appeared
on cbs this morning back in august 2019
as the new york times magazine launched
the 1619 project
an ongoing series the magazine says aims
to reframe the country's history
by placing the consequences of slavery
and the contributions of black americans
at the very center of our national
narrative the project marked the 400th
anniversary
of slavery in america we don't know
about 1619 the same way that we don't
learn very much about slavery
it is shameful no one wants to talk
about their sins or the worst moments
materials from the project have been
developed into lesson plans to use in
schools
but some republican leaders are trying
to block its use in public education
this project rewrites american history
to teach our children
that we were founded on the principle of
oppression
not freedom gop lawmakers in five states
have introduced bills to cut funding to
schools and universities that use the
project
we just want our kids to have the real
history of america to be proud of
america
in our beginnings and make sure that
they have the facts
in response to criticism about the
project's focus the times issued a
clarification last year
to its opening essay by hannah jones
noting that protecting slavery was a
reason
some of the colonists fought the
american revolution
but not all of them hannah jones stands
by the project calling it patriotic to
consider how slavery shaped the
country's origins
and continues to affect black americans
today for cbs this morning
ed o'keefe washington